uh why don't we go next to
um let's go to jamie from canada jamie
you're on the air
hey david how are you doing i'm doing
well
good i called in a couple times before
and most of my questions were
hypotheticals and i i don't know if if
it's harder to answer a hypothetical
question than a a question with the
factual basis in it um well that's uh
that question is in and of itself
hypothetical let me hear the two options
and then i'll tell you which question's
more difficult oh okay
um i was just wondering if
this is a hypothetical again this is a
hypothetical scenario i was just
wondering so say like democrats get
hypothetically sorry that's the word of
the day um
say they get hypothetically they get 52
dems and then um
then they decided to do the rules change
to like pass the what they what what
chuck tried to do back in january but
failed say hypothetically that like
mansion and cinemas are like well we're
switching parties so that it goes back
to 50 50. yes
do you see something like that happening
no
okay yeah no i don't think so okay
okay and another thing that i was just
wondering was
how do i talk to my mom about abortion
um
because well what are you trying to do
she's catholic and so she doesn't agree
with it
okay well let me ask you this is it is
it merely an academic discussion or is
there some practical nature to the
discussion
um
no i it's a it's a it's act mostly
academic mostly emotional like she says
she doesn't agree with it whatsoever she
says she she doesn't agree with it on
the on the principle of it whatsoever
well i'm curious jamie i mean you're in
canada and uh abortion is relatively
it's legal and relatively accessible in
canada is that correct
yes so i guess my question is what do
you want to achieve what's the point of
fighting this fight with your mom is it
you just want to convince her for for
some reason well no i i don't want to
fight with her anymore um
she thinks it's something that it
shouldn't be and i said well i'm trying
to say to her i suppose my arguments in
the past have been very
emotional forward and she doesn't take
too kindly to that and i suppose i just
wanted this more um factual way
of of of of you know having this
conversation with her well listen to
give to give you specific ideas we would
need to go into her people are opposed
to abortion for different reasons so you
need to kind of meet them where they are
and and we don't have the scope to do
that here but one thing i would just
think about is is this really a fight
you even want to have with your mom you
know
no no yeah so maybe you just don't
convince her you just just let her think
what she thinks i don't know yes and
she's
and um
she and you know it's funny um i don't
know i don't know if this is uh it's
funny even though i have an argument
with her on abortion um she votes um
she votes green party um
yeah
and it's interesting i know and she said
she said probably this is the last year
i'm gonna vote that way
um all right well jamie keep us posted
thank you so much there's jamie from
canada he's got his hands full up there
that's that's clear